This idea of ultimate pacifism, it's
just kind of hard to understand if you
take it to its logical conclusion. Okay,
imagine, okay, so Jesus is with us in a
room and um a horde of barbarians burst
in and start raping and mutilating women
and children. Is Jesus going to be like,
don't do anything. Don't hurt those
guys, but it's okay for the women and
children to be hurt. Like, why? What's
the logic in that?
>> Well, we never have an example like
that. We have the example of Jesus
commanding us to turn the other cheek,
right? Right. And there's a wisdom to
that.
>> But that that's a personal thing. You
can't have a society like that. That's
my point.
>> And and it would be a sin if someone
tries to rape your daughter. It's a sin
not to do something about.
>> But my point is I don't think Jesus is
saying create a constitution based on,
you know, the sermon on the mount
because if you do that, you're going to
be run down. People are going to take
advantage of you and they're going to
exploit you and they're going to run you
down. Okay? Is that is that the ultimate
message of the gospel? And again, I'm
not preaching or saying that Christians
need to be militant. I'm just saying the
bare minimum is to be Jesus said be as
innocent as doves but as wise as
serpents. Okay? So Christians are called
to be wise and prudent and it doesn't
you know so to take all these let's say
policies or actions and just think your
job is to lay down and I call them
doormat Christians and have everyone
walk over you and think somehow that
they're not going to do that. No. I mean
left to its logical conclusion if
Christianity does not defend itself just
like that quote from Teddy Roosevelt
>> which is absolutely right and I quote in
sort of scimitar somewhere I have a
paraphrase where he says if Christians
did not know how to fight and parallel
and eventually overcome the Muslims and
he talks about basically from the 7th
century to the 1700s and he's like
Christianity would have been snuffed out
because it was snuffed out in other
areas where Islam took over which is the
Muslim world. Okay, Europe could have
been like what the uh the the cops of
Egypt and the Assyrians in in Iraq and
Syria are experiencing. Is that the
ultimate vision, you know, for Christ,
that Christians must always be attacked
and abused and mauled and raped? You
know, again, it's one thing to say, oh,
Christianity is not about going on the
offensive, which I'm for that,
>> but to just say that we have to go out
of our way. um you know and and okay
I've actually been looking into this
very deeply this question and I actually
have something important to share with
you um this is a philosophical take on
why people today including you and me
possibly have a problem with violence
and how it seems so uncchristian to us
shall I elaborate
>> I'm all ears
>> okay so I think what's going on today is
that essentially modern Christians of
today despite what they think they know
or what they believe are ultimately
governed by by a materialist philosophy
just like atheists by that I mean okay
so what is materialist philosophy it's
the it's a philosophy that says I only
believe and act upon and take into
consideration that which is real okay
this is real you're real okay don't give
me so we deal with physical reality
things that I can be can be measured
seen felt quantified and discussed all
right metaphysical that word basically
means that which is beyond the physical
which is everything else which is ideas,
morality, ethics, God himself. These are
all metaphysical concepts. The atheist
tends to reject them and yeah I get the
logic because his first premise is only
that which I can see, feel, measure is
real. So everything else falls by the
wayside. Now Christians
>> and the atheist will try to build an
ethic code on top of well-being. This is
like a classic Sam Harris tried to do
this in Right. Yeah.
>> Okay. Now the Christian
supposedly believes in a host of
metaphysical truisms. All right? And a
lot of these truisms, so for example, I
was looking at recently at, for example,
the the seven deadly sins, right? Uh
pride and lust and envy and uh sloth and
gluttony and uh what else? I'm I'm
probably missing one. Anyway, and I'm
looking at them and I'm thinking to
myself, you know, that was the heart of
what Christians, this these are
metaphysical aspects and this was the
most important thing that Christians
were worried about. And look, you know,
seven deadly sins and what's not there
is death and murder and killing, isn't
>> Yeah.
>> Isn't that interesting? You know why?
Because it's a byproduct of those sins.
It's a byproduct of pride and envy and
um uh you know, greed and that sort of
thing. So my point is
back then in this era that we're talking
about, they were governed by a
metaphysical understanding. Okay? They
understood killing is bad. Okay? Murder,
of course. I mean, it's in the Bible.
Murder is bad. I'm not I'm never arguing
that it's not. But to them, there was a
whole host of other things that were
even worse. So that killing actually was
sometimes seen as a lesser of two evils.
Okay? blasphemy against God or
desecration of holy spaces or things
that and that's my point. So all these
things that actuated those Christians to
war don't make sense to modern
Christians because they're materialists
at heart. They don't to them the only
parts of Christianity which is why if
you look at modern day Christians they
care about things like yeah don't
violence is bad, killing of course
stealing is bad. Why? Because it's
physical and uh well what are the
virtues? Oh, helping the poor. Um,
helping the needy. Again, money, it's
physical. You're helping their, you
know, you're helping their material lots
of these people. But you don't hear
anymore about moral sins or moral
virtues. And that's because, I believe
modern day Christians, despite what they
say or or they claim to believe, have
been sucked into the materialist
worldview like the atheist. And so, they
prioritize the same sorts of things like
violence. Physical violence is the
ultimate evil. Okay? But it wasn't. So
from a a Christian point of view,
physical violence is evil.
>> But there's even greater evils that are
metaphysical and abstract. Okay? And
that's what those guys were fighting
against. And if it meant we have to
fight and kill, then so be it because we
had to guard the soul.
>> Yes.
>> You know the the sins that I'm talking
about that are abstract. Um this they
were evil and they were bad because they
affect and kill the soul which is all
that matters because the body is going
to die anyway. Part of just war theory
they would Augustine said that he said
we're going to die anyway. So it's
because you killed someone in in in a
just cause it's not exactly a big deal.
We're all dust anyway. It's the soul
that matters. So that I think and today
you look at our society I talk you know
pride well the the really envy is pride
and envy and lust and gluttony and sloth
those are uh not only are they not
frowned upon in our society they are the
heart of our economy. Okay. quite and I
think since the great war and the second
world war even honor and valor are no
longer metaphical things
they meant so much those words and today
what do they even mean
>> probably because of the physical
>> exactly
>> trauma of those two wars those
>> well yeah yeah that that for sure but I
guess what I'm you know I'll wrap it up
>> well I think you're on to something if I
if I might add something I think part of
the reason historians on the crusades
>> seem to do a bad job it's always very
difficult to find good histories of the
crusades because they actually can't
even conceptualize what you're talking
about.
It's they're anacronized and it's it's
quite often done in what the economic
motivations which I was going to ask but
what are the material motivations cuz
they can't possibly be any other one and
actually
yeah that's why exactly you're
absolutely right this is one of the
problems in understanding the crusades
because they see it from a Marxist
materialist lens. Okay. And um but I'm
saying it's even worse because
Christians see it that way too which is
why Christians poo poo and condemn the
knights of the temple and the hospitaler
because on the one hand these guys were
pious monks crawling on their knees okay
like literally think of a medieval monk
and then on the other hand they're at
war and they're just these valorous
fierce warriors okay which you know to
us does it's what a complete
contradiction right you're either a
doormat monk who's on the you crying or
you're a fighter. You're not both.
>> So, they were very interesting animal
this fusion and uh and very effective as
well. But
>> like I said, they didn't I they were not
materialists. So, yeah, killing is bad.
We're not going to kill someone
unjustly. But there's so much worse
that's going on that we need to fight on
behalf of
>> morality. Okay, metaphysics. That which
is beyond the physical. We have to
protect. And that's why if we have to
fight, okay, and kill, then so be it.
modern day Christian I don't think gets
that because he is a materialist which
is to say he's an atheist at heart. I
think too many Christians they you know
they just throw out formulations but
when you see the way they live and the
way they see the world it's it's really
indistinguishable from an atheistic
worldview
>> and I think a lot of people know that
deep down inside when they think about
it. So anyway, I tell you all that in
the context of just war, but also to
help make sense of these crusaders,
especially, you know, the the the
Templars and and the hospitalers, the
military orders. What's really, you
know, amazing about them is, like I
said, really emphasizing, you know, you
had what's called a secular crusader,
which was a a regular European knight or
whatever, who'd go and fight who's
obviously a Christian, but these guys
were, you know, very pious on the one
hand and very violent on the other. And
uh in my book, I actually talk about how
this even then was seen as strange
amongst some critics, but others
actually thought it was well, you know,
like St. Bernard of Clervau. He was he
was a champion for the Knights of the
military orders. Um and it's very
interesting stuff that like you said is
just completely missed by most people.
>> We actually haven't even properly
started with the crusades themselves
which is what this conversation is
supposed to be about. But there is one
thing I wondered whether it was
important to the um world view of
Europeans at that uh point was the
Constantinople which we touched on in
the Turks going increasingly west.
fight.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.